Wanda who is this?
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my Wandavision episode 5 marvel video
you did not see that coming there are so many
big twists that we have to talk about so many
easter eggs and references we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the channel
i'm doing videos for all the episodes be sure to
subscribe to get everything we're doing a giveaway
for disney plus memberships too all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and post all
your theories about the big twist in the comments
below careful for spoilers if you have not seen
the episode yet because there are some pretty
big spoilers floating around out there so many
moments and easter eggs to talk about so i'll
just number these as we go along to stay organized
probably the best episode so far just in terms
of big reveals i know everyone's just thinking
about that big twist don't worry we'll get to
that in a second but starting at the beginning
of the episode the Wandavision theme music just
sounds a lot like family ties classic 80s sitcoms
it looks very family ties but there are a lot
of blending of elements like even though we're
in the 80s here there's a little bit of full
house and i think they'll be doing more full
house references because olsen twins are elizabeth
olsen's sisters so we'll probably see some more
jokes about that in next week's episode 6 which is
going to be the halloween episode where they wear
their classic comic book costumes but it's the
halloween versions of their comic book costumes
they're trying to calm billy and tommy wicken
and speed because they're still babies right now
before they age up and they just won't be quiet so
vision starts talking about reading billy charles
darwin's descent of man which is just another one
of his books his second book on human evolution
as we see them continue to evolve throughout the
episodes then this is actually a really big deal
scarlet witch tries to use her reality warping
powers to force the twins to go to sleep and
it doesn't work on them her powers don't work on
them and she can't figure out why they referenced
this a couple times during the episode with some
callbacks like agnes later says kids you can't
control them like she literally calls it out
that's because of the way scarlet witch created
them in their mutant powers they have powers
like hers or really if you want to get technical
billy wiccan has the same types of reality warping
powers that she does so when they morph up through
the episode aging themselves up they make it seem
like they both have the ability to do that but
you could also say that billy might be doing it
himself too because he has the exact same power
she does throughout the episode they also kind
of clue you into the fact that they know what's
really going on as well like talking about her
having the ability to bring things back from death
but then we have another agnes moment when she
says no what we really need is help and she
shows up with exactly what they need as if scarlet
witch is controlling this although we also kind of
think that agnes really knows what's going on
or agatha harkness i think we're all on board
with the idea that she probably winds up being a
version of back of the hardness from the comics
like they have the big moment where she says
why don't we take it from the top again do
you want me to do this again making scarlet witch
freak out thinking that agnes really knows what's
happening with her ability to rewind time and
redo events when she doesn't like the outcome
they also use this as part of the vision story
arc during the episode and him slowly realizing
what's actually going on him finding the truth out
she calls herself auntie agnes and says she has a
couple tricks up her sleeve which i think is just
a reference to comic book agatha harkness and her
magical abilities foreshadowing tricks that she'll
pull in future episodes like telling vision that
he's really supposed to be dead then they have
the lavender moment if it seemed weird during
this scene it's because there's a lot of mythology
behind lavender some people believe that if you
hang it above the door it will guard against evil
spirits and you can add it to children's bath
water to drive demons out of them so that's just
a reference to scarlet witch's comic book children
being the soul shards of mephisto wanting to drive
the demon away so to speak expect a much more
simplified version of their origin story and how
they continue to exist after Wandavision on the tv
show then when she makes another reference to her
husband ralph using it and there's no taming this
tiger the mythology behind lavender also claims
that it quote unquote makes lions and tigers go
docile there's also a figurine of a tiger on their
kitchen table later in the episode which i think
is another callback to this reference taming
the tiger so to speak but sort of tying this
all back around too also a reference to scarlet
witch taming that tiger because she woke up this
morning and chose violence it gets crazy later in
the episode so obviously we'll talk about that too
because there's some more cool x-men easter eggs
in her big confrontation with the sword agents
a lot of x-men easter eggs in this episode just in
general not just the quicksilver stuff with evan
peters but also with some of the other stuff she
does then they have the big twists with the first
time the twins age themselves up so the way they
make it seem is that they're actually controlling
their own ages during the episode it's not scarlet
witch doing this you also notice that the clothes
that they wear throughout the episode even though
they change as they age up the color scheme for
both of them stays true to their comic book
costume color scheme but they'll just continue
to use these big billy and tommy twists for big
moments in future episodes like this is only the
beginning it's gonna get way crazier with them
then they play the new version of the 80s theme
song like they have a new theme song for all the
episodes but the whole theme song is a metaphor
for what's actually happening on the show for what
is happening with scarlet witch in her life right
now this really sappy song plays as a brush
paints their family into color but it's being
wielded with scarlet witch's telekinesis powers so
it's a metaphor for her creating her family out of
nothing like that's literally what she's doing
inside this reality she created billy and tommy
she brought vision back to life she's making her
family literally then they do the funny montage of
the family photo album showing them as kids and
adults this is so hilarious and messed up they
show a real-life picture of baby elizabeth olsen
this is actually from real life but then in the
adult picture you actually see her in sokovia in
the slums here with all this destruction behind
her and you notice that quicksilver isn't there
so the fact that all this sappy music is playing
while this is happening is just a metaphor for
what she's doing she's trying to gloss over the
really moments of her life like she doesn't want
to think about all the pain that she's experienced
then they have that hilarious vision montage like
vision as a little kid when clearly obviously none
of this is real she's making this up as they go
along they kind of reference that during episode
one as well when mrs hart says let them tell their
story they're trying to figure it out like scarlet
witch is literally writing the story as she
goes along if you listen to the lyrics of this
theme song as well they repeat that over and over
we're making this up as we go along you notice the
aspect ratio changes again going back to movie
aspect ratio but now the broadcast has actually
changed to widescreen because we're now moving
into more of the modern era of tv and because a
lot of this episode is all about vision realizing
what's really happening and then sort of blending
the fictional reality with the modern reality like
when scarlet witch literally crosses the barrier
and speaks to them with her sakovian accent she
tries to explain what it was like being stuck in
there saying that she remembers scarlet witch's
voice in her head this overwhelming feeling
forcing her to act to conform to the role that
she cast for her as geraldine in this hopeless
feeling of grief like she was drowning later
in the episode when vision is talking to norm
he references that same type of feeling so what
they're talking about is they're actually feeling
the same pain as scarlet which they're feeling
her emotions like she is drowning in grief right
now that's why all this is happening why she
created this but then they set up this big
arc of tyler hayward being a dick and sort
of setting scarlet witch off antagonizing her
pushing her to be more of a villain during the
episode and eventually during the series like
it's only going to escalate as episodes go on
darcy even literally calls him out on it like
yeah he's just an [ __ ] like that he calls her
the primary victimizer but that could mean there
are other forces in play because we'll get into
this when i talk about the big quicksilver twist
there seems like there's a little bit of other
stuff going on in the background too during the
episode there are a couple twists where scarlet
witch claims that she had nothing to do with it i
but i didn't do this i have no idea what's
going on you don't believe me but then they run
through her backstory talking about her parents
arena and oleg maximoff those are the maximos from
the comics they talk about their origin with the
mind stone referencing the events of the captain
america winter soldier post-credit scene baron von
strucker we've seen that in previous episodes and
there's been some trailer footage implying that
they'll continue to explore this idea in future
episodes as well tyler hayward keeps trying to
get jimmy wu to call her scarlet witch she doesn't
have another name an alias he keeps talking about
her being a villain and you can kind of see the
way they're positioning this like monica rambo
jimmy wu and darcy all want to be sympathetic to
wanda and help her because ultimately she's a good
character who's just going through very terrible
circumstances she's just having a really really
bad year so while the tyler hayward character
is only making things worse pushing her further
and further they're trying to help her on the dl
they also reference a couple cool avengers movies
deleted post-credit scenes during the episode as
well from different avengers movies the first
one is when jimmy wu is talking about scarlet
witch becoming an avenger he's referencing the
end of avengers age of ultron where they have
that avengers assemble moment during the original
version of that scene it was originally meant to
be captain marvel floating down this was way
before they'd ever cast brie larson's captain
marvel the whole idea was they were going to
introduce the character much earlier during
marvel phase 2 marvel phase 3 and this was going
to be the first time you actually see her show
up then the second deleted post credits scene is
actually the avengers end game Wandavision post
credit scene that kevin feige got rid of so i did
a video about this a little while ago i was really
happy that they confirmed my theory basically what
was originally supposed to happen is exactly what
you see play out during the episode paul bettany
revealed that what was going to happen after this
scene here of scarlet witch talking to hawkeye
after the iron man funeral is that she was going
to break into sword steal vision's body and just
drive away with the body bag and that would have
led them into the opening moments of Wandavision
episode 1 with this is all happening the cooler
thing too that they lay on top of this as well as
they reveal that it goes against vision's living
will he did not want the avengers to repair him or
bring him back to life however you want to think
about that but i feel like this is an answer to
the question of why they didn't bring vision back
during avengers end game because he did not want
to be brought back per his will and the avengers
were respecting that so they just want to hype up
more of scarlet witches going completely off the
rails she woke up and chose violence this morning
but while they're talking about scarlet witch's
grief they focus on monica rambo with the camera
because they want her to have some common ground
with her they both lost loved ones like they have
the big scene in episode four where she realizes
that her mother has died so she would understand
the grief that scarlet witch is experiencing right
now and she'd be sympathetic to her in a way
that the other sword agents like tyler hayward
are not sympathetic to her they set up the big
vision versus scarlet witch moment at the end
of the episode when they say what happens when
vision learns the truth then when they go back
inside the house of mr reality they introduce
sparky the dog from the tom king vision run the
dog was also named sparky during that comic book
run but in that story it was an android created by
vision because in that version of the story vision
is the one that creates the family for himself and
they're all androids then she starts using her
powers in front of everyone like she says she's
not trying to hide it anymore she creates the dog
collar agnes also does not think that it's weird
and then she does this later in the episode too
they sort of reference it again when the giant
dome the bubble around the house of m reality
changes to red and becomes visible to the naked
eye like she says she's not hiding anymore she's
not hiding this alternate reality then they have
the next big twist of the twins aging themselves
up 10 years so that they can keep the dog in just
reminding you that they do have powers of their
own and they can't be controlled by scarlet witch
the way that she's controlling everyone else then
they jump back into the normal mcu reality and
they have that funny moment of jimmy woo happily
bringing darcy and monica rambo coffee paying off
the darcy coffee scene from episode 4 where she
was complaining about nobody bringing her coffee
when they're trying to find a way back into the
alternate house of m reality monica rambo says
she knows an aerospace engineer who'd be up for
the challenge of designing a vehicle to get them
back inside a lot of people wondering who this is
and i do think it'll wind up being someone special
i think the vehicle that they're talking about was
from one of the trailers so they will pay this off
eventually but i don't know who the person is
going to wind up being a lot of people are like
is it victor von doom because he's an engineer is
it another fantastic four reference is it going to
be adam beshear is it going to be the blue marvel
because everybody's been wondering when he's going
to enter the mcu and he is an engineer just like
she says it could be but they're going to reveal
what's going on with that in next week's episode
so we'll see if they actually tell us who that
person is or if they wait to reveal that to the
captain marvel 2 movie because right after this
they make a captain marvel reference because her
powers come from the space stone just like scarlet
witch's powers are connected to the mind stone
another infinity stone but then the way they play
the scene off makes it seem like there's some
drama between monica rambo and captain marvel
because she doesn't want to talk about it she's
like we're not talking about her and then just
brushes it off even jimmy wu thinks that it's kind
of a weird reaction like he looks at darcy going
wait what's what's going on here like he senses
there's some tension with captain marvel i assume
that they're gonna pay that off during captain
marvel 2 because that is where monica rambo is
going to show up next in the mcu after Wandavision
they also start arguing about the technicalities
of how things exist in the alternate reality
wait is she creating them out of nothing is she
just reshaping things that already exist that's
what the whole kevlar pants twist is with monica
rambo's 60 looking getup like oh she's rewriting
reality which is a big twist for her re-writing
quicksilver's character she recast quicksilver
but then they have the big moment with vision
at his company sort of realizing what's going
on with the email they make more references
to vision being an android you're like a walking
computer it's almost like you speak their language
they wind up intercepting an email from the sword
agents they don't explain exactly how they wind up
intercepting it but it's based on darcy's findings
envision learns about the quote-unquote maximoff
anomaly which some of the people in sword at least
darcy is calling the hex she literally talks about
that oh it's shaped like a hexagon so i'm trying
to call it the hex the big easter egg there is
that it's also a reference to scarlet witch's hex
powers in the comics and if you actually read that
classic vision in scarlet witch miniseries
the story about their relationship together
you notice that some of the comic book frames
are shaped like hexes which i think is another
callback to that episode one outro scene where the
frame turns into a hex and then it zooms out into
the regular mcu reality while darcy's watching
the broadcast i talked a little bit about the
other hexagon easter eggs during my Wandavision
episode 5 trailer video hexagons are a shape
that show up in nature pretty frequently because
mathematically they've been proven to be a much
more efficient shape than actual circles or other
shapes structurally they're also incredibly strong
because they're made up of a bunch of triangles
and triangles are the strongest shape but in some
of the ways that they use them on the Wandavision
series they're meant to be comic book references
then they reveal that the twins also know about
how time moves differently in here why is dad at
work if it's saturday no it's not saturday it's
monday and then scarlet witch tries to brush it
under the rug like she just tries to blow past
it like oh it's no big deal just weird stuff
happening but then they have the big twist with
the sword drone we find out that tyler hayward
secretly armed it with a missile seeming like he
was actually trying to kill scarlet witch straight
up take her down like take her out now take the
shot they try to make it pretty clear that monica
rambo was having no part of that she didn't know
what was actually going on love the moment where
you see scarlet witch on the broadcast monitors
her eyes light red and she destroys the drone then
comes out to issue her ultimatum notice that
when she steps out of the barrier and starts
speaking to them her sokovian accent comes back
and she's wearing her regular avengers costume
she changes her 80s clothes back to her modern day
costume monica rambo tries to get her to chill out
just finding some common ground but she claims
she already has everything she needs and says
no one is ever going to take it from her again
when she turns all their guns on them it's meant
to be a reference to the original x-men movie
where magneto her comic book father has a very
similar type of scene going up against a bunch
of police officers you homo sapiens and your guns
this is the first big magneto easter egg that i've
seen but it's not quite the same thing as them
doing the evan peters quicksilver thing from the
fox x-men movies so i'll explain the difference
so we haven't actually seen actual magneto on the
show yet hopefully there'll be some big magneto
twist later on or some bigger easter egg then
we get our next commercial and it's really funny
in a way it's meant to be a parody of a brawny or
downy paper towel ad but lagos is the name of the
city where they were at the beginning of captain
america civil war where scarlet witch accidentally
wound up killing all those innocent people when
she was trying to stop the hydra attack the red
liquid is meant to be a reference to the blood
that she spilled oops a mess that you need to
clean up then as they go out searching for sparky
they pass the mailman who also seems like he knows
what's really going on because as he passes them
he references scarlet witch not letting sparky
get far because she's controlling everything
don't worry your mom won't let him get very far
it just seems like something weird is going on
with that mailman so keep your eyes peeled on
him for the next couple of episodes they wind
up at agnes house and she claims that sparky
died because he ate too many of her azalea plants
which are actually toxic to dogs in real life then
they turn it into this big teachable moment
about death and not trying to run from your
grief the kids try to age themselves up before she
stops them no no don't try to run from your pain
and a lot of what she's talking about is exactly
what she's doing like she ran from her pain to
create this fictional reality the twins remind you
that they know what her powers are you can bring
him back from the dead please do it mommy and just
as she's talking about not bringing things back
vision walks up i also love agnes's reaction to
that too she's like wait a minute you can do that
like she's also realizing that she can bring stuff
back from the dead but then they don't address it
later but then as they end the episode vision
tries to talk to scarlet witch about norm he
starts calling her out on this fictional reality
and everything that's going on she tries to avoid
the conversation she doesn't completely deny
it but she just tries to blow past it like all
right it's time for bed let's all go the credits
start playing in front of them but they continue
to argue while the credits are happening you
remember during the episode that monica rambo
darcy and jimmy wu figure out that scarlet witch
is controlling the broadcast the edits the way
they see everything so the reason why the credits
cut out after they continue arguing into the next
room and vision automatically changes back to
his normal appearance is because vision is kind
of interrupting scarlet witch's conscious
mind from transmitting this broadcast feed
her powers from working the way that she wants
them to because she has to focus on the argument
that she's having with him he says he doesn't
really know anything about himself he doesn't
remember his life before they came to westview
because she's controlling everything about him
she also kind of challenges him on that notion too
when he says you can't control me like you control
everything else and everyone else in here and she
says can't i because technically she reanimated
him she is kind of controlling him then just as
she starts talking about not understanding how all
this started she sounds like she's being truthful
when she says that too i don't know how any of
this began she doesn't really understand how her
powers are working the cosmic radiation from her
abilities warping reality around her the doorbell
rings and it's evan peters x-men quicksilver
but recast is mcu quicksilver within the narrative
of this fictional reality now in the credits for
the episode he's only listed as pietro they don't
list him as quicksilver but a lot of people are
just wondering what this means is this them
blending the multiverse elements of the fox
x-men movies with the mcu movies is this sort of a
lead-in for how they explain deadpool from the fox
movies ryan reynolds deadpool showing up in the
mcu movies eventually or is there something else
going on with this twist is evan peters playing
somebody else pretending to be pietro but if you
actually listen to his performance you actually
watch the way he behaves he's not acting like
mcu quicksilver and he's not acting exactly like
his fox x-men quicksilver either the vibe he's
giving off is kind of like a douchier version of
his fox x-men quicksilver character but according
to scarlet witch she is not responsible for the
doorbell ringing so she's claiming that she's
not responsible for quicksilver showing up here
so it could be evidence of some outside forces
influencing some of what's happening during the
scenario it could be a hat tip for more doctor
strange 2 stuff more setup for the villain during
that like nightmare or even mephisto so we'll just
have to wait and see for more episodes because
it sounds like it's just one of the first of many
twists behind this quicksilver twist like first he
shows up but then there's way more stuff happening
with this character than they've let on i do love
the rug pull moment that they go out on and when
he says hey who's the popsicle pointing at vision
revealing that he knows that vision is really dead
like i said twist within twists within twists so
everyone post all your theories in the comments
below about what's really going on with evan
peters quicksilver showing up do you think
it's actually fox x-men movies blending with the
mcu movies or do you think he's actually secretly
some other character just pretending to be pietro
i'll talk more about this during my trailer video
for episode six so that'll post tomorrow but
leave all your questions in the comments below
and if there any big easter eggs that you
spotted that i didn't mention in the video
just write them below in the comments as well
everyone click here for my brand new Wandavision
fantastic four easter eggs video and click here
for all my other Wandavision episode videos
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!